Ранкова гімнастика...
Безкоштовні обіди...
Та цілий пакет з канцелярським приладдям для першачків.
Велика папка для ручної праці...
А ще - повний набір різних послуг: від миття автомобіля…
Ми старалися дезінфікувати громадський транспорт,
в якому їздить велика кількість людей протягом дня.
Такий "креатив" перед місцевими виборами в Україні вже є традиційним.
Нині ж мотивація політиків, схоже, зашкалює.
Адже внаслідок децентралізації місцеві можновладці отримали більше повноважень.
Зріс і бюджет громад, яким вони можуть розпоряджатися.
Тож, аби отримати доступ до "годівнички", деякі політики часу не гаяли
і почали агітацію ще задовго до офіційного старту виборчої кампанії 5 вересня.
Розпочала роботу гаряча лінія "Стоп-Коронавірус".
Так ще в квітні кандидат на крісло мера Львова Ігор Васюник
почав дбати про тілесне здоров'я львів'ян.
А ось колишній президент України Петро Порошенко - про духовне.
На початку вересня до львівських виборців приїхав не з порожніми руками.
я хочу подарувати сертифікат на 500 тисяч гривень…
Паперовий сертифікат конвертується в гроші для відновлення храму,
а зустріч з вірянами - в підтримку партії
"Європейська Солідарність" на місцевих виборах
Показованабожність політиків - це фішка західноукраїнського регіону,
каже регіональний активіст руху "Чесно" Олексій Роговик.
Політики підбирають, як через церкву впливати, допомогають церквам.
Заходами, спільні молебні...
У нас це теж є.
На Західній Україні - це спільний молебень з кандидатом.
Або якщо свята, то пасочки роздавали.
Політики враховують місцеву специфіку,
те, що люди в світоглядному конструкті в себе мають
і використовують це, щоб більше під них підлаштуватися.
Які тут цінності домінують, такі і подарунки дають.
Турне регіонами влаштував і чинний президент Володимир Зеленський.
На тлі стрімкого падіння рейтингів партії "Слуга народу"
та за відсутності яскравих кандидатів у регіонах він взявся агітувати особисто.
За останній місяць об'їздив ледь не всю Україну.
На Сумщині знайомився з будівництвом доріг.
На Хмельниччині відкривав школу, на Одещині - садочок.
Побудований якісний дитячий садочок.
Все закінчено, все побудовано.
Люди раді, й це було зроблено...
Словом, президент робить все те, з чого ще два роки тому сам кепкував зі сцени.
Партія "Опозиційна платформа за життя" йде традиційним шляхом.
Тисячі пакунків з гречкою, рисом, олією
роздавали одиноким пенсіонерам та ветеранам війни на Сході України.
Задобрювати виборця почали також ще навесні.
А це на Херсонщині люди слухають агітацію за партію Ігоря Колихаєва.
Нардеп, який входить в комітет аграрної та земельної політики,
вочевидь має свій баштан. Ось і привіз людям безкоштовні кавуни.
При цьому надання будь-яких товарів, робіт чи послуг,
які супроводжуються агітацією за кандидата чи партію
чи хоча б згадкою імені, є непрямим підкупом виборців.
Якщо вартість товарів менша, ніж 63 гривні 6 копійок,
порушники притягуються до адмінвідповідальності.
Принаймні згідно з законодвством.
За дорожчі товари і послуги, а також продукти харчування,
спиртні напої та тютюнові вироби, незалежно від їхньої вартості,
перебачена кримінальна відповідальність.
З року в рік спосіб підкупу виборців, втім, удосконалюється.
Так, тренд цього сезону - це виборчий туризм.
Адже нове виборче законодавство дозволяє змінювати виборчу адресу і на місцевих виборах.
Це, з одного боку, дало можливість для голосування
внутрішньо переміщеним громадянам,
з іншого - несе ризик зловживань.
Ноу-хау цієї кампанії - це підкуп виборців через зміну виборчої адреси.
Особливість у тому, що підтверджуючих документів,
чому людина змінила виборчу адресу, не потрібно
І насправді були факти, коли так робилося.
Є кілька класичних прикладів - це Затока, Кароліно-Бугаз,
Фонтанка Одеської області, в Запорізькій були випадки,
в Київській області, зокрема, в Бориспольському районі.
Лише в одній громаді зареєструвалося
300 нових виборців. Це багато.
Ці історії розслідує поліція. Подивимось, що буде далі.
Знайти 500 студентів, які
будуть не проти відпочити в Затоці,
плюс їм щось заплатить за те, що вони проголосують.
Проживання, проїзд і так далі,
як для Одеської області,це непоганий варіант для кандидата і цих людей.
Утім, жарти жартами. Але бюджети, які політики вкладають у місцеві вибори,
за масштабами не поступаються передвиборчій кампанії до парламенту.
За підрахунками руху "Чесно", за останні 8 місяців лише на рекламу у "Фейсбуці"
політики витратили півтора мільйона гривень.
Скільки ж коштували матеріальні блага чи розваги для виборців, порахувати неможливо.
Не вдасться вирахувати цю суму і зі звітів політиків,
каже Віта Думанська - лідерка руху.
Адже звітуватимуть політики тільки за осінні витрати - з часу,
коли кампанія офіційно стартувала.
Однак наскільки великим є вплив тих же безкоштовних кавунів,
гречки чи олії на остаточний вибір людей?
Є психологія українців - це психологія вдячності,
що ти комусь щось зобов'язаний.
І дуже часто чуємо від людей, що всі крадуть,
але цей хоч щось дав. Я візьму і буду голосувати по совісті.
Але відчуття, що будуть голосувати за того, хто дав.
Слова експертки несподівано відразу підтверджують випадкові перехожі у Києві…
Кличко виділяє по 100 по 200 і по 250 гривень отримували -
брали, для нас це багато означає.
Тільки за нього.
хто малозабезпечені, він піде на це..
Знаєте, у нас життя яке...
А можна брати й не голосувати?
Можна, але я не знаю як в душі буде в чоловіка...
По совісті треба,
а.. а совість - це така річ, що мучає.
Тільки пресу роздають, а так нічого не пропонують.
Путівку на Кіпр не пропонували.
Колись у нас був дуже хороший чоловік. Онищенко.
Це дуже добра людина, він для нашого району зробив багато.
Він і світло робив, і дороги зробив.
І там, де годами не було, тепер світло.
Крадуть усі, а діляться не всі.
Хто хоче, хай бере, бо люди бідні у нас.
А я не беру, не брала і брати не буду.
Злого умислу в агітаційних подарунках українці, однак, схоже, не бачать.
Люди мають розуміти, що те, що вам принесли -
це спроба купити доступ до місцевого бюджету.
Бо треба розуміти, що депутати не отримують компенсацію за свою роботу.
Тому маємо розуміти, що якщо людина готова інвестувати десятки тисяч доларів
в свою виборчу кампанію - в гречкосійство,
це означає, що вона розраховує отримати гроші назад.
І ці гроші будуть отримані з наших з вами бюджетів.
Іерез тендери, відкати, лобіювання свого бізнесу.
Аби не допустити ласих до бюджету громади політиків,
антикорупціонери радять використовувати своє право голосу сумлінно -
не лише не піддаючись спокусі агітаційним подарунком,
а й відповідно реагуючи на спробу підкупу виборців.
Та радять у таких випадках звертатися до поліції.
Чи будуть такі зловживання розслідуватися, покаже час.
Наразі не відомий жоден випадок, коли політик поніс відповідальність за підкуп виборців.